[Musique]
bonsoir martin mc colis merci d'être
avec nous alors pourquoi que joe biden
s'est choisi le royaume uni pour son
premier déplacement à l'étranger
un jeu pour place du bail il est très
important pour le président en personne
se rend au royaume uni car il a beaucoup
de problèmes
c'est un taux d'approbation très élevé
dans de nombreux pays d'europe donc il
faut il veut faire une bonne impression
il se rend donc au royaume uni pour
rencontrer corrélation sonne il veut
prendre l'initiative et dire à boris
johnson qu'il doit résoudre le problème
irlandais le cette frontière entre la
mer d'irlande entre l'irlande du nord et
le royaume uni
car cela sape les accords du vendredi
saint
c'est très important et du fait de son
origine des leçons origines familiales
il a droit à s'exprimer très important
et il doit dire à boris johnson qu'il
doit résoudre ce problème les risques
henson ne peut pas résoudre le problème
tout seul lord france tu dis que l'union
européenne ne répond pas aux initiatives
britannique
ils demandent à l'union européenne
d'accepter des compromis afin d'avancer
les deux côtés doivent trouver des
compromis pour johnson expliquera à cela
au président byden lorsqu'ils se
rencontreront à londres alors ont
toujours cette relation spéciale entre
le royaume uni et les etats unis est ce
toujours le cas on sait en tout cas pour
ce qui concerne cette relation entre les
deux hommes que tout billet n'était pas
nécessairement le choix de boris johnson
qui s'entendait plutôt bien avec donald
trump le président entrant avait une
relation spéciale avec le royaume uni il
avait même un golf en écosse la relation
avec le président biden
différentes c'est car il est d'origine
irlandaise et l'irlande a été très
longtemps une colonie britannique tient
colonie anglaise donc il faut garder
cela à l'esprit n'y a pas la même
relation instinctive avec londres avec
l'angleterre que donald trump
mais joe biden c'est qu'il est très
important pour les etats-unis de
développer le multilatéralisme et cela
passe par développer de bonnes relations
avec le royaume uni s'assurer que le
royaume uni et les etats unis tombent
d'accord sur les grands problèmes
internationaux l'union européenne est
également importante
l'occident en général est important
c'est que je baille tu n as dit que
l'occident devrait se rassembler afin se
fédérer afin de défendre ses intérêts
contre la chine
l'intérêt principal pour joe biden à
londres et lorsqu'il se rendra en europe
et de forger des alliances encourager la
compréhension
sachant que les états unis travailleront
avec l'union européenne avec l'oreille
une mi temps la poursuite de leurs
intérêts communs afin de lutter contre
l'expansionnisme chinois alors le
royaume uni ayant quitté l'union
européenne on précise d'ailleurs que joe
biden était contraint ce break site est
ce que c'est maintenant l'occasion
d'être pragmatique et d'en faire un
partenaire commercial privilégié lui
aimerait avoir une relation spéciale
notamment une relation spéciale
économiques avec les états unis ue où
les mâles que je peux jouer le président
train tu aurais bien aimé avoir un
accord entre les etats-unis et le
royaume-uni ou entre les états unis
l'allemagne mais l'union européenne qui
agissait en tant que l'union a empêché
un train de créer des accords pays à
pays et on peut considérer que les états
unis que le l'union européenne n'est pas
assez conscience concernant cette
frontière irlandaise et boris johnson va
sans doute demander à être pas été
utilisé son influence à bruxelles afin
de faire avancer la situation car il
faut résoudre ce problème
cette barrière de la mer d'irlande
handicap
les relations entre le royaume uni et
irlande
il faut que cette situation soit résolue
avant de former une relation commerciale
spéciale entre les états unis et le
royaume uni merci beaucoup martin mc caw
lee analyste politique d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france d'avoir
évoqué donc cette première étape de la
tournée de joe biden qui va atterrir
dans la soirée à londres là où vous vous
trouvez